This is Cameron.
You probably recognize him from
some other courses around Udacity.
>> Hey everybody, it's good to see you.
>> So Cameron, we've been working
through stuff with frameworks.
>> Yes, frameworks are awesome.
No, I love frameworks,
they're so much fun.
You get to build your app and
just think about the logic of your app,
without worrying about all the nuances
that go into making your app
work at the lower levels.
>> That's right, and frameworks, the
developers have already created a bunch
of different components that you
can just stick together, and so
you don't actually have to worry
about any of that complexity at all.
>> Yeah, it's fantastic,
like for instance, templating.
Usually there's some kind of HTML that
you want to display over and over, or
display differently in
different situations.
And so with templating,
you can just define that once,
say what kind of information you
want to go inside that template, and
then when that data changes on your app,
the template automatically changes, and
it looks great.
It's easy,
you don't have to think about it.
So at the end of the day, your workflow
is so much faster and more efficient.
>> That's right, and another thing
is that they also handle events,
so you don't actually have to
worry about atEvent listener or
managing state at the dom.
[CROSSTALK]
>> That's awesome, it's great, yeah.
There's so much you don't have to
worry about, because you have the best
developers in the world, usually,
working on these things.
Maybe that's a bit of an exaggeration,
but they're really good, and they know
what they're doing, and so you're not
really building this app by yourself.
You're building on top
of their expertise,
which means that your app is
going to be more performant, and
there's a lot that you just don't
have to do, which is great.
>> That is great, yeah,
less work is better.
>> Definitely, the best code, or the
code that has the least chance of being
a bug, is the code that you don't write.
There's probably a better way of
saying that, but you get the idea.
>> Exactly, yeah.
Okay, so we're looking at angular and
ember and
some other frameworks in this course.
But each framework is different, and
each one provides its own set
of benefits and detractions.
So there are lots of different things
you need to keep in mind as you're
looking for a framework.
>> Yeah,
everyone is slightly different, they all
have their own different philosophy.
They all have their way of doing things,
and
they all also have different features.
Usually, sets of features
are fairly similar, but
there can be some differences, so
it's definitely worth experimenting with
different frameworks to see
which one you like more.
And then when it comes time
to build your project,
it's worth thinking about
what's going to go into it, so
you can make the best decision about
which framework best fits your needs.
Sometimes there's not necessarily a best
framework, it's just what you're most
comfortable with and what you think
you can move the fastest with.
>> Right.